[Music]  we were concerned mostly about whether  they develop an attitude right well  they're not and they are you know sweet  kind funny smart respectful people  that's President Obama gushing over  daughters Sasha and Malia with his final  days as president upon us POTUS reflects  on raising his two girls in the White  House was it a good experience for them  you know you don't know how it would  have turned out if they'd grown up in  Chicago instead in a more normal  environment all I can say is they have  turned out to be terrific  young way Obama opens up to George  Stephanopoulos in an exclusive interview  on this week the one thing the girls  didn't enjoy during their time there the  Secret Service but as you might imagine  if you're a teenager having a couple of  people with microphones and guns always  following you around that can great on  them but you know they've handled it  with grace the president credits first  lady Michelle Obama for just how well  they've done  you